Okay, so you saw that the UI button has
an intrinsic size based on the text and
image it may contain.
That means we only need two constraints
to center this button on our view.
One for the x coordinate, and
one for the y coordinate.
There are two ways to add these
constraints, and I'll cover both here.
With the record button selected,
you can click on the align button
that looks like a bar graph.
If you're having trouble
finding the record button,
remember to use you document
outline here and select it there.
With the record button selected,
click on the align button,
which looks like a bar graph here,
and then select these two options on
the bottom to center it horizontally and
vertically in the container.
And then select add two constraints.
We can now see both constraints in the
record button in the document outline.
You can expand these triangles if
you want to see them actually here.
And, if you're like me, you may have
encountered the first on a layout issue,
which is these orange lines
that you see here, or
this yellow disclosure here
that you can see at the top.
Now, let's fix that
first before we run it.
So if you click on this tiny arrow,
we can see that Xcode expects that our
button be on X of 276, width of 29 and
height of 30, and its height is 32.
So if we expand this
out a little bit and
click on this one,
we can get it to fix the frame.
That is to fix the size of the button so
it matches the constraints
that we've declared.
We'll do that.
We can see it's trimmed a record
button to fit just the text or
just intrinsic size of our button.
Let's see if adding
these constraints works.
Let's select the iPhone 6s here
on the simulator drop down, and
press the run button, or
hit command and r on your keyboard.
We should see the record button
on the center of the screen.
With the iPhone simulator selected,
press and hold down the command key, and
then use the right or
left arrows to rotate the simulator.
I'm going to use the right arrow here
to rotate it to landscape right.
And I can use the left arrow
to rotate back to portrait.
In both orientations, we can see that
our button stayed in the center.
Now let's try it on an iPad Air 2
which is a lot larger than iPhone 6s.
If I move this to the side,
we can go back into Xcode,
and press the stop button.
We can here in the drop-down
select an iPad Air 2 and hit run.
Now we have a record button, but
it looks like our iPad simulator
is too big to fit on our screen.
What do we do?
We could go out and buy a large tunnel
of display, and I would recommend that.
We could petition Johnny Ive to bring
back the 17 inch Macbook Pro laptop.
Well, there's an easier option.
With the iPhone simulator selected,
let's go in to window, and then scale.
And you can choose
a different size here.
For example, let's do 33%.
That makes our iPad a lot smaller.
And we can see it.
We can use the command keys to jump
around between those sizes, too.
For example,
Cmd+3 will get us a little bit bigger,
Cmd+2 will get us even bigger and
now it's, again, offscreen.
So let's stick with Cmd+3.
Here you can see the record button is
still in the center of the screen,
even if I use Cmd and arrow keys to
rotate the iPad to landscape right,
or back to landscape left.
By the way, these options just scale
down the size of the ioS simulator as
a whole to what you're seeing.
For your app,
everything is still the same size.